die dunkle materie soll für unsere
existenz für die existenz des menschen
verantwortlich sein board die frage
warum es uns menschen gibt beschäftigt
wissenschaftler und wissenschaftlerinnen
schon immer jetzt stellt eine us
amerikanische forscherin eine radikale
theorie auf dunkle materie soll dafür
verantwortlich sein dass die dinosaurier
ausgestorben sind und wir menschen uns
entwickeln konnten
das geheimnis liege in der oortschen
wolke die von der dunklen materie
beeinflusst wird krieg zum science
fiction dienstag gespannt des seins
videos abonniert den kanal und activity
glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen die meisten
paläontologen und paläontologin sind
sich einig dass vor etwa 66 millionen
jahren ein ringen sie gar körper
vermutlich ein komet auf die erde traf
und der einschlag 75 prozent aller
spezies auslöste dadurch bekamen andere
später jetzt wiederum die chance sich
weiter zu entfalten zu den überlebenden
gehörten kleine primaten die sich im
laufe der zeit weiter entwickelten
manche wurden größer erlernten den
aufrechten gang und entwickelten große
gehirne die menschen lisa randall hat
eine überraschende neue theorie dazu wie
die menschheit entstehen konnte sie ist
theoretischer physikerin an der harvard
university und stellt in ihrem buch
dunkle materie und dinosaurier ihre neue
theorie auf rente ist eine renommierte
wissenschaftlerin sie erforscht die
theoretische teilchenphysik und
kosmologie und ist autorin mehrerer
wissenschaftlicher bücher und des new
york times bestseller das verborgene
universum eine reise in den extra
dimensionalen raum in ihrem neuesten
buch stellt sie jetzt die these auf dass
das aussterben der dinosaurier das
notwendig für die entstehung der
menschheit war mit dunkler materie in
verbindung steht dunkle materie
das ist ja die mysteriöse unsichtbare
materie die nach schätzungen von
astronomen und astronomen 85 prozent der
gesamten materie im universum ausmacht
wandel beschreibt in ihrem neuen werk
eine dunkle pfannkuchen förmige masse in
unserer galaxie die dicht bepackt mit
dunkler materie ist diese masse ist laut
der wissenschaftlerin dafür
verantwortlich dass unsere spezies
entstehen konnte
man muss dazu sagen dass dunkle materie
nie direkt festgestellt werden konnte
aber es gibt zahlreiche indizien für
ihren enormen gravitations
einfluss auf unser universum aus diesem
grund geht die mehrheit der
wissenschaftlichen welt davon aus also
nicht alle aber die meisten das ist
diese unsichtbare mysteriöse materie
gibt sie bildet meist einen kranz um
galaxien oder ist in großen blasen
konzentriert rendel nimmt an dass es
zwischen den sternen planeten und
gaswolken auch eine so genannte dark
disc also eine dunkle scheibe gibt in
dieser soll es vor dunkler materie nur
so wimmeln und dadurch hätte didaktik
einen mächtigen gravitations einfluss
auf die objekte um sie herum also auch
auf unser sonnensystem unser
sonnensystem bewegt sie schwankend in
zentrum der milchstraße alle 32
millionen jahre passiert unser
sonnensystem dabei die milchstraße und
nach rendel auch die taktik tatsächlich
gibt es hinweise darauf dass es auf der
erde alle 25 bis 53 millionen jahre ein
massenaussterben gibt ist das nur ein
kratzer zu fall
randall und ihr harvard kollege matthew
ries wollten dem auf den grund gehen und
eine verbindung zwischen der massen
aussterberate und der schwung rate
unseres solar systems durch die galaxie
erstellen die vermutung ist dass während
wir die disc durchqueren die orte wolke
das ist die äußere region unseres
sonnensystems von der anziehungskraft
der dunkle materie beeinflusst wird
in der wolke befinden sich milliarden
von einigen objekten die mindestens 19
kilometer groß sein sollen wenn ein 19
kilometer großes einziges objekt unserer
erde treffen würde wäre das leben das
wir kennen vorbei so soll es vor 66
millionen jahren auch gewesen sein als
die dinosaurier ausgelöscht wurden und
der weg für unsere revolution geebnet
wurde die theorie der tag des muss
renner noch beweisen dazu sucht sie
sterne die sich auf eine art und weise
bewegen die man nicht mit der menge an
sichtbarer materie erklären kann das
würde auf die existenz der dax ist
hinweisen ist aber ein echtes sisyphus
arbeit denn es gibt etwa 100 milliarden
sterne in der milchstraße okay ein
update zum thema gibt es vielleicht
nicht mehr in diesem jahrzehnt dunkle
materie erklärt von 100 sekunden physik
cooles video anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran